- It's deeply anti-intellectual
and it's frankly racist.
I think we should call it out
for what it is.
- It's racist.
- If you look at the kind of
white supremacist ideology
of the 1950s, which
we all denounce,
it has the same categorization
as the critical race
theory ideology of today.
You reduce people
to a racial essence.
Back then and today, it's
whiteness and blackness.
You create a group
identity-based hierarchy.
Again, it's different,
but it's the same concept.
And then these critical
race theory trainings
are essentially
denouncing people,
not on their individual
characteristics,
but on their inborn identity.
This is something that
was wrong in 1950,
it's wrong today, and we
should be very on high alert
and we should all
be working together
to jettison this ideology.
(somber music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and
this is "The Rubin Report"
As always, guys, make
sure you're subscribed
on our YouTube channel
and have that notification
bell clicked on.
And joining me today
is a research fellow
at the Discovery Institute's
Center on Wealth,
Poverty, & Morality,
and contributing editor
at the "City Journal,"
and perhaps more importantly,
Mr. Critical Race Theory
himself, Christopher Rufo.
Welcome to the Rubin Report.
- It's great to be with you.
- What do you think
about that title,
Mr. Critical Race Theory?
- (laughing) I think it's
a little bit misleading,
because I think a
lot of the proponents
of critical race theory
would disagree with that.
They would say I'm kind of Mr.
Anti-CRT more than anything.
(both laughing)
- All right, well,
we're gonna discuss that
for the next half hour and then
we'll let the people decide.
So really why I
wanted to have you on
is you're one of the people,
at least in the Twitter world,
although now you've
made it to Tucker,
so that's a nice bump,
that has been explaining
critical race theory
clearly and honestly and openly.
And it is a set of ideas that
basically has infiltrated
almost every part of society
and has so much to do
with why we're seeing
such chaos at the moment
and why everybody is sort of
picking their set of facts
or their worldview, and we
can't come together on anything.
So I really wanna just
unpack all of that with you
so that my audience can
understand it a little bit more
because I think when you
say critical race theory,
people don't know
exactly what it means,
there's a lot of different
definitions, all that.
So just one thing quickly
before we do that,
which is how did
you get involved
in all of this in
the first place,
and then we'll
take it from there.
- Yeah, I've been reporting
the last two years
on homelessness,
addiction, mental illness,
and kind of West
Coast street disorder.
So this has been a
bit of a departure.
But it all started when I
got the whistleblower email
that said, hey,
the City of Seattle
is now holding racially
segregated diversity trainings,
and the segregated system
for white employees
is called
"Interrupting Whiteness
and Internalized
White Superiority."
And this just immediately
piqued my interest.
I filed a records request.
I forgot about it for
a couple of months
and then got this
trove of documents in
that was just astonishing.
I've been following the
kind of conceptual ideas
of critical race theory
for the last few years,
but this was the first time
I'd see it really implemented
in a way that was crystal clear,
that was extremely divisive.
And then once I
released them publicly,
it kind of took on
a life of its own,
and I became really
the kind of key source
for whistleblowers
in every institution
in the United States,
and since then,
I've had more than 1,000
whistleblowers contact me,
everything from the
smallest school districts
in middle America
to the highest levels
of the federal agencies.
And they're all saying
that critical race theory
has become the dominant
ideology in these institutions.
It's ripping us apart, but
we're scared to speak out,
and that's why we're
contacting you.
- Yeah, and that's why I thought
this was such an
interesting topic
because for the years that
I've been doing my show,
I've had on an
awful lot of people
who have been
fighting these ideas,
but there wasn't sort
of a name around it,
there wasn't like
a way to look at it
through at an
institutional level.
So when you're getting
all of these emails
from little institutions up
to the big federal stuff,
it's like I've been
seeing these emails
for the last five years,
and we've been seeing Bret
Weinstein at Evergreen State,
what happened, and
Lindsay Shepherd,
and just the litany of examples
of people fighting this thing.
Okay, so let's just do 101 here.
What is critical race theory?
- So that's a question
with a thousand answers,
but the best that
I can describe it,
it's basically you take
the Marxian dichotomy
of oppressor and oppressed.
So you have one group in
society that is the oppressor,
one group that is the oppressed.
Traditionally, that's
been the bourgeoisie
and the proletariat.
So it's an economic
stratification.
Critical race theory
basically contends
that we're going to do away
with the economic
categorization for now
and we're going to essentially
graft identity politics
onto this Marxian dichotomy
so that it's no longer the
bourgeoisie and the proletariat.
It's whiteness and blackness,
it's white Americans
versus people of color.
So that's really what it is.
It's an old Marxist idea
that's been repackaged
with the racial
politics of our time.
- So do you see a
moment where it went
from an economic theory
to a racial theory?
Was there just like a
moment that that happened
or did it just slowly
infect the whole thing?
- Yeah, I think
there's many moments.
It's a lineage that is
a pretty long lineage,
but if you can trace it back
to the Frankfurt School,
and the Frankfurt
School theorists,
I guess now 50
years ago or more,
really realized that economic
Marxism had its limits.
They realized that it
couldn't make inroads
in Europe and the United States
because we had too
big of a middle class.
In the United States, you
have a suburban house,
you have an automobile,
a washing machine,
and people didn't really feel
that the oppressor/oppressed
dynamic of social class
was really speaking to them.
And so the kind of
Marxist theoretician said,
"We're not gonna make
success that way.
Let's figure out how we
can set up a new dynamic
that could be more salient."
And unfortunately, this works.
It is something that I
don't think has much basis
in reality or in fact,
but it's tremendously
powerful psychologically.
And you have in our elite class
has really adopted this rhetoric
that I think has no basis
in their daily life,
but it's become a
very potent weapon,
a very powerful weapon
that's found resonance
because it combines this kind
of innate American discomfort
about race and then weaponizes
it into a political tool.
- Does it strike you as
deeply anti-intellectual also?
I mean, that's the part that
is sort of amazing to me.
When you see it seep into the
places of higher education
that are supposed to be
about intellectualism,
and yet they're
taking a set of ideas
that whittles us all
down to our skin color
as if that's the
most important thing,
it seems like it's
deeply anti-intellectual,
not actually intellectual.
- Yeah, it's deeply
anti-intellectual
and it's frankly racist.
I think we should call it out
for what it is.
- It's racist.
If you look at the kind of
white supremacist ideology
of the 1950s, which
we all denounce,
it has the same categorization
as the critical race
theory ideology of today.
You reduce people
to a racial essence.
Back then and today, it's
whiteness and blackness.
You create a group
identity-based hierarchy.
Again, it's different,
but it's the same concept.
And then these critical
race theory trainings
are essentially
denouncing people,
not on their individual
characteristics,
but on their inborn identity.
This is something that
was wrong in 1950,
it's wrong today, and we
should be very on high alert
and we should all
be working together
to jettison this ideology.
And I think something
that's really important
is that if you look
at Martin Luther King,
the kind of gold standard
of how we should think
about the country,
how we should think about race,
his philosophy was deeply
rooted in Christianity.
He was obviously a preacher,
but it was also deeply
rooted in the Declaration
and the Constitution and
the work of Abraham Lincoln.
He was a student, you can
read this in his essays,
he was a student
of American history
and realized that we
had to bring forward
the highest ideals
of the country.
The Black Lives Matter movement,
the critical race
theory movement,
they self-consciously
reject the ideology
of Martin Luther King,
they reject the ideology of
the Declaration of Independence
and they reject the ideology
of Christianity wholesale.
It's a different lineage.
It comes from the
kind of Marxist
theoreticians of the 1960s
and has no resonance
in our kind of organic,
homegrown, cultural tradition.
- Do you see what
they want to build
on the other side of this?
That's the part that
is unclear to me.
I get all of the bad ideas here.
I think a lot of my audience,
because we've been talking
about this stuff forever,
gets a lot of the bad ideas,
but it seems to me
that I can't really see
what they wanna build.
I can see what
they wanna destroy,
which is pretty much everything,
which is what we see
happening right now.
Hollywood's crumbling,
our cultural institutions
are crumbling,
our academic institutions
our political institutions
are crumbling.
They've infected everything.
So I get the destruction phase,
but do they even
really talk about,
the people that buy into this,
do they ever really talk about
what they will build after this?
I mean, is it really
going to be a world?
Are we going to have
anti-white laws?
Is that really where we're
headed with this whole thing?
- Yeah, I mean, there's two
ways to look at that question.
One is you're absolutely right.
Critical race theory and
critical theory in general
is not a philosophy of
substantive positive.
It's a philosophy
of pure negation.
They're arguing that
they should deconstruct
existing social institutions,
point out how they're kind
of coded for racial dominance
and oppression, and
then obliterate them.
They're not clear,
and this goes back all the
way to Marx in the 1840s.
Marx posited that we have
to have the revolution.
We have to destroy
the social order.
We have to destroy all of
the kind of underpinnings
of our society, but even
Marx gave no clarity
on what the world
looks like after that.
It was pure utopianism.
There was no concrete
plan or development,
or even a vision of
what would happen.
It's really this blind faith
that if you destroy what's bad,
something beautiful and good
and eternal will emerge.
But our history in the
last 150 years globally
has shown that that's
absolutely wrong.
When you demolish
a social order,
when you empower ideologues
that divide people
on the basis of group
identity, it leads to famine,
it leads to war, it
leads to genocide.
It leads to everything
that is bad in the world.
And I don't see the
critical race theorist
positing something
substantive in its place.
And I think what
you can also see,
the second way of
looking at this,
is that if you look at the kind
of in practice what emerges,
look at the CHAZ.
You remember the Capitol Hill
Autonomous Zone in Seattle,
Black Lives Matter and
anarchists took it over.
They said, "Once we
get rid of the police,
once we get rid of the
Seattle government,
once we have our
own kind of utopia,
we are going to
set up a government
based on social
justice principles."
And what happened?
They set up racially
segregated facilities.
There were meetings and
gardens and elsewhere
that were explicitly
endorsing racial segregation,
and it devolved into
a violent nightmare.
It had a homicide rate
that was 50 times greater
than the city of Chicago.
It led to the senseless death
of African American men,
and it didn't work.
And although that's obviously
a very small example,
I think it's an important one
because it gives a kind of
glimpse into what happens
when you demolish law and order,
when you demolish the
existing social order,
and you try to replace
it with a utopian vision.
- So one of the questions I
get all the time from people
is they'll say, "Dave, why
is it spreading so quickly?"
It's almost as if you weren't
paying attention to this,
like if you weren't watching
the few YouTube channels
about it or the podcasts
or whatever, you suddenly,
it was as if it never existed
and then one day it burst
forth, and now it's everywhere.
Have you thought about that?
Just sort of how it has been
able to spread its tentacles.
so seemingly quickly,
even for the people
that saw it coming for a while,
it does seem like there was
suddenly like a catalyst
that really exploded it
in the last six months.
- Yeah, I think you're right,
and I thought a lot about that,
and I'm basing it
really empirically
on talking to folks
in these agencies,
in these institutions, who
have been unable to resist it.
And I think the
explanation is really this.
Critical race theory, the
intellectual argument of it,
is constructed almost
like a mousetrap.
It's quite ingenious, and
embedded in the premise
is that if you oppose
critical race theory,
that's merely an expression
of your white privilege,
of your white fragility,
of your internalized
white superiority,
and they make any
resistance, any disagreement,
they just rationalize
that as a proof
that you are the thing that
they're fighting against.
So it's constructed
in a circular way
where you can't truly
fight back against it.
And they're using a very
kind of bare-knuckled,
social shaming and social
castigation process,
where if you even raise your
hand in one of these trainings
and say, "Well, you know, this
is a little bit simplistic.
I see it in a more nuance way.
I see it in a more complex way,"
you're going to be berated
by at least one person
in the room who
says you're a racist
or a white supremacist or
a fascist or what have you.
And frankly, most people who
are working a regular job,
they're raising families, they
don't wanna take the risk.
The social pressure
is so extraordinary
that they essentially
just sit and take it.
But I think what
we're finding out,
in the last few
months especially,
is that people have
had enough of it.
It goes against
their experience.
It's tearing apart workplaces,
and people are starting
to finally speak out.
I think your show, certainly
Weinstein and James Lindsey
and Peter Boghossian
and Helen Pluckrose,
they laid a
theoretical foundation
against critical race theory,
but what I'm trying to do and
what others are trying to do
is trying to put
that into action
and actually elevate
some of those ideas
into a position
of political power
in fighting against
critical race theory
in every institution
in the United States
and not giving an inch,
because if we allow this
to essentially take over
our public institutions,
in my view, it's the
beginning of the end
of our constitutional order
and a system of government
that has shown a steady
capacity to adapt and progress
for nearly a quarter millennia.
- Man, it's like everything
you're talking about,
it sounds alarmist
and yet it's the stuff
that we all now know to be true.
I've been screaming about this
without having the
words exactly for it.
There was a bunch of us,
you just named a
couple of the people,
that were screaming about it
and everybody kept
saying, "No, no, no,
it's just a bunch
of college kids."
That was the criticism
I was getting often
from mainstream media.
It'd be, "No, no, it's
a bunch of college kids.
You guys are making it up."
I wonder, have you thought
about this a little bit,
that it seems to me
that the liberals,
the good remaining
liberals, whoever they are,
there's not that many left
because I think so many have
been sort of either silenced
or coerced into this
crazy lefty thing,
do you sense that the liberals
have any defense against this?
I think this is where I
have a bit of a difference
with some of my friends in this
where I think some
of them still think
the liberals have some defense
mechanism against this.
I simply don't
believe that anymore.
I think it's either
the conservatives
and in a weird way,
it's Trump or bust.
What do you think about that?
- Yeah, I 100% side with you.
And I think that what
we've seen in Seattle
and San Francisco
and Los Angeles
that the kind of
old line liberals
or the kind of moderate liberals
really have no
ability to push back
or even restrain the most
extreme progressive ideologues.
And that kind of experience
in the last 10 years
in these very liberal
cities on the West Coast
is now being nationalized
in our discourse.
And frankly, Joe Biden
is not gonna offer
any kind of restraint
against this.
It's completely naive
and absurd to think so.
I think it's also kind
of naive and absurd
to think that there is some
great third party unity ticket
that could fight against it.
The kind of brass tacks of it
is that a kind of dissonant
liberals, mainstream liberals,
they have to create an
alliance with conservatives
in order to stop this, and I'm
encouraging all of my friends
on the center left to move
over and forge an alliance,
at least on these
critical issues with us,
within the
conservative movement,
because the bottom
line is really this,
writing an op-ed, no
matter how good it is,
appealing to civil discourse,
appealing to restraint,
appealing to the center, is
not gonna change the minds
of the fundamentalists
who are running
the kind of intellectual
architecture of the left,
and they have to basically
make the decision,
we are going to tactically
align with conservatives
to stop this.
And I think there's precedent.
If you look at the 1970s,
who became the kind
of neo-conservatives?
These were a lot of
New York intellectuals
that were liberals,
that were in some cases
even on the very far left,
and they were mugged by reality.
And then they moved
over to the right
and became prominent members
of this kind of big tent
conservative infrastructure.
The same thing has
to happen today,
and I'm really pleading
to all of those folks
on the center left,
look at the actual political
landscape as it exists,
not as you imagine it in
your hopes and dreams.
Let's get together,
let's push back,
and let's exert some
actual political muscle.
- Chris, honestly, I don't know
that I've ever been more
relieved by an answer
that I've ever gotten
from a guest on the show,
because as you know,
that is what I believe
and it's causing a
certain pain point for me
with a lot of what I
would say is my old crew.
It's the liberals that
can't accept that.
But do you think some of that,
the inability to understand
the landscape as it is
not as you want it to be,
do you think some of
the aversion to that
is simply because of Trump,
that if it was somebody
else fighting this stuff,
they could get on board,
but because it's Trump,
they can't get on board.
- Yeah, I think that's
a big part of it.
And you know, I'll
be very honest.
I've been very honest
with my own views,
I didn't vote for the
president in 2016.
I shared a lot of
the reservations
that a lot of the people
on the center left shared,
but I've realized that
the world as it is,
is a binary system.
That's been our political
system for almost 250 years.
That's how it's going to be for
the next at least 100 years.
So we have to operate in A or B.
And for me, it's a
very simple choice.
You have Joe Biden, who
essentially at this point
is a kind of armored carapace,
where he's going to bust
through to the Oval Office,
and then the people who
are driving the movement
of progressivism are
going to man the agencies,
are gonna man the
kind of facilities
and push this ideology
even faster, or Trump.
If you have reservations
about his character, I get it.
about some of those policies,
I get it, but he's
come out very strongly
in the last 30 days.
He's denounced critical
race theory by name,
and he is the only politician
in the United States,
frankly, that
would have done it.
Jeb Bush would be
hiding under a desk.
He wouldn't wanna
touch this issue.
And I think that the
president for all of his flaws
is someone who's willing
to stand against this.
And you don't have
to like your allies.
You just have to recognize
from a pragmatic point of view
that you are fighting
the same battle
and when then that battle's won,
you can go back to
your separate sides.
But I think that
I've come to realize,
the president has
earned my vote,
specifically because of
his action on these issues.
And I would encourage
folks if they have to,
hold your nose and pull
down the old lever.
- I'm so with you on that,
and I'm glad that you explained
it as cleanly as you did,
because I think the problem
with the last remaining liberals
is they want to write
the Harper's letter.
They wanna say all the things,
address all the problems,
as long as they can say, "Oh,
but we don't support that guy"
who's actually doing the
work to fix the thing.
So can we talk about
that a little bit?
That Trump is
actually doing things
to get critical race
theory out of our system,
and of course he's being
called a racist for it.
You talked to Tucker
about this a little bit.
Can you talk about what
Trump has actually been doing
and not just talking about?
The libs are all good at
talking about the things.
He seems to be
actually doing things.
- Yeah, the president
after following
some of my reporting
on critical race theory
and federal agencies,
he immediately tasked his
OMB director, Russ Vought,
to issue an executive
action at his request
to abolish all critical
race theory trainings
throughout the
federal government.
This is a pretty bold move.
And then he followed
it with a speech
at the National Archives
where he dismembered
the ideology of
critical race theory.
In actually kind
of a surprisingly
intellectual dialogue
where he called it out by name,
he linked it to
the 1619 Project,
he linked it to the
riots in the streets
that have been going on since
the death of George Floyd,
and he says, "These are all
kind of birds of a same feather.
These are all
interlinked phenomenon,
and I'm gonna stand against it.
I'm gonna essentially
put myself in the breach
and fight against it on
principle and in practice."
And I think a lot of our
friends on the center left
are willing to
fight in principle,
but they're not willing
to fight in practice,
and this is a kind
of huge error.
I look at it like
this, they were saying,
"We don't want
Trump to fight this.
We don't want him to
create this executive order
banning critical race theory."
And I'm saying, well, okay,
that's essentially saying
we wanna keep losing, because
if we win a little bit now,
there might be a backlash.
That frankly is a
defeatist attitude.
I find it totally
untenable on the level
of prudential politics, and I
would again encourage everyone
to abandon that way of thinking
and have some
courage and step up.
- Yeah, it's one
of those things,
I liken it to like the
barbarians are at the gate
and the one guy who's
guarding the gate still,
you got all the
intellectuals going,
"Ah, he talks funny
and his hair is crazy."
And it's like, guys, (chuckling)
we got a bigger problem
on the other side of that gate.
So then after Trump
issued this speech
and everything
else, then the CDC,
they said they were still
gonna continue, right?
But then he put an
end to that as well.
- Yeah, it's actually
multiple federal agencies.
I've reported new
whistleblower documents
from the CDC, the EPA, the
Veterans Administration,
and the State Department,
all of which are moving forward
with critical race
theory trainings,
in direct violation of
a presidential order.
And I think this is both a
problem substantively, right?
The kind of principles
that are in these documents
are divisive,
pseudo-scientific, racist,
and really destructive
for the workplace.
But it's also a
problem at the level
of our constitutional system.
The president is the president.
He controls the agencies,
and my friends and colleagues
at the Claremont Institute
and elsewhere have long warned
about the administrative state
becoming the unconstitutional
fourth branch of government.
And I think this is another
illustration of that pattern
where you have mid level
and even senior bureaucrats
basically saying, "We can
openly defy the president.
We're gonna do what we want,
even though nobody elected us,
and we don't have this
power in the Constitution,
we're gonna keep doing it."
So I think in the short
term, this is not a big deal.
The OMB director
will shut these down.
But in the long term, on the
kind of theoretical basis,
this is a major problem.
You have an administrative state
that essentially
doesn't think of itself
as beholden to the
political order.
and I think that
is a huge problem
and we've gotta tackle
that when the time comes.
- In effect, you're talking
about the deep state there
when you say the
administrative state.
Do you make a distinction
or you just don't
like that phrase?
- Yeah, I think I
don't like the phrase.
I think there's a really
strong body of scholarship
on the phrase, the
administrative state.
I think the deep state
can kind of verge
into conspiratorial territory.
So it's a personal choice, but
I think administrative state
is on much more solid
intellectual footing,
and we have a long list of folks
who have done the background,
done the homework,
done the reading,
that I would encourage
everyone to look up.
- So let's say through
this executive action,
Trump is able to get this stuff
out of the federal agencies.
It sounds like it's still
gonna be a fight to do so
and who knows if that's
even really possible,
but let's just say that
that kind of works.
Are you worried then
that what will happen
is we'll have federal agencies
that will have
removed this stuff,
but in effect, we'll just have
all the private institutions,
the private schools,
all of our businesses,
our television networks,
all of these things,
they will still be infected,
and that infection will
almost create a situation
where the federal government
will be unable to operate
because the outside forces
won't let the federal government
do what it's supposed to do,
something to that effect.
- Yeah, I would kind of
contextualize it in this way.
I think we've long been
concerned about this
for the last few years,
but this is the first time
that we've actually gotten
anything done about it.
I think it's really
substantively
the first successful pushback
against critical race
theory in our institutions,
but it's not the first.
This is really the opening
shot in a long war.
And I think that we can
start with federal agencies.
We can start with other
public institutions.
We can kind of shut off
the spigot of funding
that goes towards the
university programs
that are creating this
intellectual framework.
We can go after local
school districts
and local institutions
that are funding this.
And then what we do is
we change the calculation
for corporations that I think
will adapt very quickly.
What we need to do is we
need to raise the cost
of doing these programs,
because right now
the kind of risk management
protocol for corporations
is, well, we really don't
lose anything by doing this,
but we insulate ourselves
against the attack
of being a big, bad corporation.
And so what they're doing
is they're protecting
their economic prospects
with our existing policies,
and this is a way
of risk management
for their social policies and
social status in the world.
What we have to do is we
have to change that formula,
where we significantly
escalate the cost
of doing these programs.
And I think the
next step is clearly
a kind of campaign of legal
warfare against these programs.
Peter Kirsanow and others
have argued persuasively
that these constitute
workplace harassment,
that these violate the
Equal Protection Clause
and the Civil Rights Act.
And I think that's
the next step.
And I really think
that I'm excited,
I'm energized by
this initial victory.
We have a long way to go,
but I think that if
we work together,
we get our heads
out of the clouds
and we actually fight, kind
of swords out on the ground,
I think we can win this
because I think the vast
majority of Americans,
if they actually find
out what this theory
is advocating for, would
wholeheartedly reject it.
- Yeah, I'm with you, man.
Do you think that there's sort
of a micro way of fighting
and a macro way of fighting?
So it sounds like Trump and
what you just described there,
that's sort of the macro level.
We have to fight it at
the governmental level.
But one of the questions
I get all the time,
especially from
college people is,
well, how do I fight
it just personally
if one of my friends has
been just wholly brainwashed
by this set of ideas?
And I don't know that
there's a great answer.
I'll tell them, well, you can
share some Prager U videos
or listen to Larry Elder or
read a book by Thomas Sowell,
but that's sort of
all intellectual
stuff in a certain way
that often you're not
gonna get younger people
to take the time to do.
Do you have any tricks
on the micro level
on how to wake
people up about this?
- No, I don't.
Actually, I've come to
the personal conclusion
that the kind of
micro level one-on-one
is probably a waste of time.
You find yourself
debating some dude
you went to high school with
on a long Facebook thread.
It never goes anywhere.
I think that this
is really at heart
an institutional battle.
You have to win it
institutionally.
So rather than arguing
with your roommate,
you should be waging a kind
of sophisticated campaign
against the dean of your school.
And I think that's
the way to do it.
I think that, unfortunately,
we're in this really awful
political environment
where in order to maintain
kind of one-on-one friendships,
sometimes you just have to
put politics off the table.
So I think, again, it's
an institutional fight
and that's really where the
most progress can be made.
- Yeah, so I said to you
right before we started
that I wanted to keep this
exactly to a half hour,
because this is
the type of video
that I want people to be
able to say to their friends,
even if what you're
saying is right,
that you don't wanna be
debating the Facebook friend,
here's a half hour video.
Hopefully you got some of it.
So for people that do
wanna explore this more
and your work more,
where can we send them?
- Yeah, come to my website.
It's Christopher
Rufo, R-U-F-O, .com.
I'm on Twitter @realChrisRufo,
again that's R-U-F-O,
and join the fight,
join the fun.
We are really waging a
very active campaign.
We're trying to get things done.
And my motto is
swords out, swords up,
because that's what
it's gonna take.
- Chris, for real, you are
fighting the good fight.
And I like the fact that
you're enthused about it.
I know even for me, we get
beaten down by this stuff.
You wake up every morning
and there's another
thing on Twitter
about another
institution that failed,
or just like some
other horrible story,
and it can get you down.
But you got a smile on your
face in the midst of this,
which is actually pretty great.
- You gotta be a happy warrior,
and I know without a shred of
doubt that we're gonna win.
It might take time,
there will be losses,
but we're gonna win this fight.
- Christopher Rufo,
thanks for joining us.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.